Benim üzücek 9 sınıf örencileri coğraf
kar okuluna YouTube'un en büyük coğrafi
kanalına Hepiniz hoş geldiniz Z takımı
Paraf okula destek kampımızı bugün
geldik 3üncü gününe ilk gün ne yapmıştık
coğrafyanın konusunu öğrenmiştik sonra
coğrafyanın bölümlerini öğrenmiştik
Sonra bir video daha atmıştım
coğrafyanın konusu ve bölümleri ile
alakalı test sorusu çözmüştü o konuyu
iyice pekiştirmiş bugün 3üncü gündeyiz
niçin coğrafya öğrenmeliyiz coğrafya
biliminin gelişimi oradaki coğrafyaya
katkı sunan bilim adamları vesaire var
onları öğreneceğiz bakın Bugün artık
Birinci üniteyi bitiriyoruz bu konuyu da
bu videoyu da öğrendikten hemen bir saat
sonra ünite genel tekrar videosu
atacağım ünite genel tekrar videosunda
alıştırmalar olacak o alıştırmaları
beraber dolduracağız bütün ünitenin
genel tekrarını yapacağım sana bakın Ne
kadar güzel ilerliyoruz ilk önce
konuları öğreniyoruz test sorularını
çözüyoruz ünite bitiminde de genel
tekrarla beraber bütün üniteyi şöyle
yiyip yalayıp yutuyoruz merak etme
sınava kadar çok güzel bir şekilde seni
hazırlayacağım ama sana bak şu uyarıyı
yapayım dikkat et konu anlatımı yaparken
hafıza teknikleri kodlamalar
kullanıyorum bu kodlamalar Aman bunlar
çok saçma Aman bunlar benim aklımda
kalmaz ben bunları ezberleyeyim diye
yaklaşma Bakın bu kanalın 1 milyon artı
takipçisi var Ve bunu 3 senede yaptı bu
öğrenciler Niye bir coğrafya kanalını 1
milyon kişi takip ediyor Sizce hem de 3
senede Demek ki burada başka bir şey var
Öyle senin aklına yatmadı ya bu
kodlamalar çok saçma deme hiç tahmin
edemeyeceğin şekilde sınavda da aklına
geliyorlar hafıza teknikleri ve çok
işine yarıyor saçma deyip geçme çok
yenisin bu tekniklere çok işine
yarayacak Bunlar hatta bütün lise
hayatın boyunca sen bunları başka
derslerde de kullanacaksın bakın
coğrafyaya coğrafyanın bölümlerini
öğrenirken bir sürü şey öğrendik orada
şu an hepsi aklında limnoloji dedim ha
hocam Göle limon sıkıyordu Göl bilimi
diyorsun bana jeoloji jeo jeo jeo yer
jeo yer hocam yer jeo yerdi petrografi
Pedro deli Pedro kafaya taş yiyordu taş
bilmi hayat bilme bak hepsi aklında
Bugün de mesela coğrafya yardımcı
bilimler öğreneceksin Onların da
göreceksin bir sürü ezberlemesi gereken
şey var bu ezberlemeleri altından
kalkamazsınız gençler sadece coğrafya
dersi yok Bir sürü ders var bunların
hangi birini Ne zaman ezberleyeceksin
sınava hangi ara bir daha çalışacaksın
şu an bu kampı doğru düzgün düzenli bir
şekilde takip ettiğinde sınava çalışmana
bile gerek kalmayacak hafıza teknikleri
kodlamalar hayat kurtarır bunu bir iki
defa çalışırken öğreneceksin lisede Her
şey değişiyor ilkokulda lise
ortaokuldaki gibi olacağını düşünme
lisede sağlam bir şekilde sağlam
kanallarla çalış Evet ben hazırım
kalemimi elime aldım sen de beğen tuşuna
basıp abone olarak hazırsan o zaman ne
diyoruz Yunus hocayla bir defa öğren bir
daha asla unutma gelin şu derse Paraf
atalım geldik gün 3 niçin coğrafya
öğrenmeliyiz coğrafya biliminin gelişimi
pdf'i zedu van.com sitesinden
indirebiliyorsunuz gençler orada bütün
pdf'ler imiz var Bizim sadece benim
değil bakın konu anlatımları bios hemde
biyoloji mes gemi kimyada kimya var
fizik finito da fizik merkeze teyet
geometri bıyıklı Matem matematikli
matematik kısmını aynı Benim anlattığım
gibi konu anlatımı tekrarlar yazılı
hazırlıkları şeklinde yapıyor pdf'i
siteden indirebilirsiniz niçin coğrafya
öğrenmeliyiz sorumuz bu coğrafya dersi
bize ne katıyor Hatta şöyle biraz
yaklaşalım mı Sizinle şöyle bir bu kısmı
bir konuşalım şimdi bakın okuldayken
şöyle bir cümle kuruyorsunuz değil mi ya
hocam bu bizim gerçek hayatta ne işimize
yarayacak diye bir cümle kuruyorsunuz
değil mi İşte o cümleyi coğrafya dersi
için kuramazsınız neden Hele ki sizin bu
müfredatını da çok çok daha güzel oldu
geçmiş müfredatlı bilmemen gereken saçma
sapan bilgiler öğreniyordu Onların çoğu
alındı AYT kısmına koyuldu Şu an 9 ve 10
sınıfta tamamen hayatın içinde bilmen
gereken şeyler koyuldu sana ve bu o
kadar değerli ve önemli ki Neden Bir
coğrafya öğreniyorsun hayatı
öğreneceksin bu derste hayatı derken
Rüzgarları yağmuru dışarıda gördüklerini
zaten öğreniyorsun ama bir de beşerinin
insanın yaptıkları var bunların
etkileşimi var bu derste bunu
öğreniyorsun bu şeyler doğa ve insan ın
bu etkileşimi senin hayatında o kadar
çok var ki günlük hayatında Sen farkında
bile değilsin işte o farkında olmayı
sana coğrafya dersi sağlıyor sağlayacak
doğal afetler oluyor bu doğal afetlerin
neden olduğunu coğrafya dersi sayesinde
öğreniyorsun orada neden olduğunu senin
niye daha fazla etkilediğini ya da diğer
ülkedekiler daha az etkilediğini ya da o
doğal afetlerin çok fazla etkilerinde
yaptığın eksikliklerin ne olduğunu
suçluların kim olduğunu yapılmayanlar
yapılanları her şeyi görebil biliyorsun
Neden Çünkü Coğrafya dersinde doğal
afetler göreceksin depremin Niye bizim
ülkemizin neresinde neden olduğunu başka
yerde niye olmadığını olduğunda
insanları nasıl etkilediğini Neden
bunlara karşı önlem alamadığımız ve
birçok şeyi coğrafya dersi sayesinde
öğreniyorsun Bakın bu sadece doğal
afetler kısmı bu sadece konumuzun bir
kısmı nüfus öğreneceğiz mesela nüfus
öğrendiğinde nüfus konusunda göçleri
göreceksin nüfusu göreceksin ülkelerin
nüfusunun ve bizim ülkemizin nüfusunun
artışını bu artışın ülke ekonomilerine
etkisini artmayan ülkelerin ülke
ekonomilerinde yaşadıkları sorunları
göçleri göç almak zorunda neye
kaldıklarını ülkelerin ya da bizim
ülkemize gelen göçler mültecilerin ne
olduğunu bu mültecilerin ülke
ekonomisindeki etkilerini bütün her şeyi
nüfusta öğreneceksin Al sana coğrafya
dersi hayatın tam içinde iklimi
öğreneceğiz mesela sonra iklimdeki bazı
bilgileri öğrendikten sonra sen neden
kış mevsiminde sıcaklığın düştüğünü
yazın niye sıcaklığın arttığını hangi
bölgelerde nelerin yetiştirilip
yetiştirilemez
sıcaklıkların nasıl arttığını dünyayı
nasıl mahvettiği ve küresel iklim
değişimiyle hayatımızın nasıl
değişeceğini bütün hepsini bu derste
öğreniyorsun tarımı öğreniyorsun
madenleri öğreniyorsun madenlerin
ülkemizin neresinde çıkartıldığını bunun
ülke ekonomisinde nasıl bir etki
yapabileceğini gerçekten çıkartılıp
çıkartılmadan kandırılmış musun
madenlerin çıkartıldığını biliyorsun
bileceksin öğreneceksin hangi tarım
ürününü nerede neden yetiştirdiğimiz o
Tarım ürününün oradaki bölgedeki
insanların ekonomisinde her şeyinde
nasıl etkili olduğunu Coğrafya dersinde
öğreneceksin yani coğrafya dersi hayatın
tam içinde olan bir ders dışarıda
gördüğün iklimlerden dışarıda gördüğün o
bitkilerden toprağından insan tarafında
ekonomisinden tarımından hayvancılığında
insanların ilişkisine kadar Göçe nüfusa
kadar doğal afete kadar bu derste
öğreniyorsun coğrafya niçin mi
öğreniyorsun hayatına anlam katmak için
öğreniyorsun işte Çünkü Hayatının her
alanında bunlar var bu yüzden coğrafya
öğren bu yüzden coğrafya öğreneceksin
coğrafya öğrendiğinde sen artık olaylara
olgulara mekana farklı bakan birisi
olacaksın dışarıda baktığında bakan
değil gören olmaya başlayacaksın
İnsanların buradaki geçimlerini onlara
etkilerini insanların oradaki ikliminin
insana etkisi tarıma etkisi Sonra onun
ekonomilerine etkilerini bütün bu
bağlantıları kurabileceğin bütün bunu
coğrafya sağlıyor İşte bu yüzden
coğrafya öğreniyoruz Bu yüzden coğrafya
öğreneceğiz ve senin Türkiye'ye bakışın
ülkeye bakışın ülkedeki bölgelere
bakışın bulunduğun çevreye bakışın her
şeyin değişecek yorum yapma yeteneğin
olayları algılama biçimin birçok şey
değişecek İşte bu yüzden coğrafya
öğreneceksin niçin coğrafya öğreniyoruz
cevabı işte bu şimdi gelin ders kısmına
geçelim aslında çok şey öğreniyoruz
değil mi coğrafyada İşte bu kadar çok
şey öğrendiğimiz için bu kadar değerli
olan bir ders yani aslında Düşünsenize
hayatın tam içinden her şeyi öğreniyoruz
tarımından madenine ekonomisinden doğal
afetine her şeyi öğreniyoruz bilinçli
oluyoruz değil mi Biri Bizi kandıramıyor
Burada deprem oldu işte şundan şundan
dolayı oldu şöyle insanlar böyle yaptığı
için oldu dediğinde ya ne alakası var
diyoruz kimse bizi kandıramıyor
madeninde de kandıramıyor
hayvancılığında da tarımında da bilgi
birikimine sahip oluyoruz İşte bu yüzden
coğrafya dersi sevilmiyor ve
olabildiğine müfredattan elenmeye
çalışılıyor gençler Aslında coğrafya
dersi sizin en çok seveceğiniz ders
Çünkü hayatın tam içini öğreniyoruz bu
derste ilk konularda bu böyle olmasa da
şimdi haritayı falan öğreneceğiz bundan
sonra derslerde ama ondan sonra hep
hayatın içini öğreneceğiz göreceksiniz
ve lise boyunca coğrafya dersi en çok
sevdiğiniz ders olacak iddia ediyorum ve
göreceksiniz lise bittiğinde coğrafya
sizin kültürünüzü çok ciddi derecede
bakış açınızı değiştirecek niçin
coğrafya öğreniyoruz un cevabını size
anlattım yani burada yazan cümleler de
aslında bu benim size Az önce
anlattıklarım neden coğrafya
öğrenmeliyiz anlamışsınızdır diye
düşünüyorum gençler şu kısmı değineyim
ama şimdi coğrafya kısmı yani şimdi biz
coğrafya öğren Ken ya da bir konuyu
incelerken şu soruları soruyoruz bakın
Ne olmuş Nerede olmuş Ne zaman olmuş
neden orada olmuş bu olay neden önemli
bu Olayın meydana geldiği ortamın
özellikleri doğal ve beşeri ortam ile
ilişkileri bunları ezberleme sadece şu
dikkat et bir olay gerçekleşmiş baştan
sona onu irdeleme burada neden olmuş
Niye burada olmuş da başka yerde olmamış
bunun insana etkileri ne olmuş aslında
hayatın ne olduğunu inceliyor coğrafya
İşte bu soruları sorduğu için Hayatın ta
kendisi gelelim geldik şimdi sen
coğrafya öğrendin Tamam niye coğrafya
öğrendiğimizi gördük coğrafya öğrendin
coğrafya öğrendin nasıl bir bakış açısı
kazanacaksın bir en önemlisi harita
kullanmayı öğreneceksin haritayı
bileceksin O yüzden demiştim ya sana
temel atmak istiyorsan ilk olarak 7
günlük dünya haritaları kampını
bitireceksin atlasım ı bitirip öyle
geleceksin diye harita Bizim her şeyimiz
Sen haritaları bildiğin zaman yorumlama
becerin farklılaşıyor ve değişiyor sonra
Şunu fark ediyorsun coğrafyada kaynaklar
sınırlı birçok doğal kaynak diye
dersimiz olacak ya bir bakacaksın ki ya
bu kaynak L sınırlı ve bu kaynakları Biz
çıkarırken kullanırken çevreye tehdit
oluşturuyor muuu bunu fark edeceksin bu
derste olayların risklerini ve aynı
zamanda fırsatları göreceksin mekanı
göreceksin ve bu mekanla doğal ve
insanın etkileşimini anlayacaksın üç
boyutlu olarak ve bu sana yorum yapma
yeteneği kazandıracak tutup bir
fabrikayı evleri tarım alanında kurmaman
gerektiğini anlayacaksın tarım alanının
nasıl kullanılması gerektiğini
bileceksin deprem riski olan bir yeri
öğrenip bu yerde tım arazisinde ev
yapmaman gerektiğini toprakta ev
yapmaman gerektiğini ya da yapacaksan da
binanı ona göre sağlam ve sağlıklı
yapman gerektiğini öğreneceksin gidip
kayaya daha temeli sağlam yerlere bina
yapacağını öğreneceksin en önemlisi
burada zaten hepsini konuştuk artık
olayları sadece yerel çerçevede
düşünmeyeceksin yani sadece kendi
bulunduğun bu çerçeveyi ya da Türkiye'yi
düşünmeyeceksin bu yaşanılan olayların
bölgesel olarak etkilerini Hatta Küresel
çapta düşünebilir hale geleceksin bu
olayları çay üretim mi denildiğinde Aa
bu sadece Türkiye'de yetişmiyi Asıl bu
Güneydoğu Asya'da yetiştiriliyor
diyebileceğin oradaki bağlantıyı
kurabileceğin Bütün bunlar coğrafya
sayesinde olacak göreceksin doğal
afetleri de öğreneceksin bu derste
Türkiye'nin tarımını da Türkiye'nin
madenlerini de Türkiye'deki nüfusu
mültecileri göçleri de Türkiye'deki
ekonomiyi de öğreneceksin Bu ders Yani
bu derste ülkeni bölgeni dünyayı Bütün
bunların tam ortasında da kendini ve
yaşadı ğın o anı doğal ortamıyla beraber
öğreneceksin bu derste hayatı ve bunu
yaşarken çevreye bakma değil görmeyi
öğreneceksin Evet bu derste öğrenmeye
başlayalım artık tabii onları öğrenmeden
önce bir de coğrafyanın gelişimi kısmını
öğrenmemiz lazım şimdi buraya kadar az
önceki gördüğünüz kısım Aslında klasik
coğrafya nasıl öğrenmeliyiz neden
öğrenmeliyiz diye bir paragraf öğretmen
Klasik bir soru olarak sorabilir size Bu
da gayet basittir Sen de yazarsın oraya
hocam coğrafya hayatla iç içedir
coğrafya gördüğümüz doğal afetlerinden
iklimine birçok şeyi yorumlayacak
şekilde Az önce Benim sana anlattığım
şekilde bir paragraf yazıp Önüne
koyacaksın hocanın o basit çünkü onu
yorumlamayı öğrendin Az önce ben de sana
anlattım ama bakın Bundan sonrası biraz
daha zorlayıcı coğrafya biliminin
gelişimi asıl önemli olan kısım da
burası Neden biliyor musun sınavda sana
puan kazandıracak ya da kaybettirecek
kısım Burası Çünkü ezberlenmesi gereken
birçok coğrafyacı var onların bir de
eserleri var ve bu eserler ve bu
coğrafyacılar karşına ayrıntılı bir
şekilde çıkacak O yüzden biz de bunu
ayrıntılı öğrenmeliyiz öyle yazarak
hemen geçerek olmaz bak uyarıyorum seni
sınavda yazılıda karşına bu
coğrafyacılar buradaki dönemler Çıkacak
O yüzden geleceksin şimdi benimle
beraber ayrıntılı öğreneceksin Bitmedi
bu ayrıntılı öğrenmeyi yaptıktan hemen
sonra bir video gelecek ünite genel
tekrar videosu ünite genel tekrar
videosunda etkinlikleri yapacağız test
soruları çözeceğiz onları da
izleyeceksin bu iki konu anca öyle pekiş
ÇK ve sınavda ben sana Garanti veriyorum
90 üstü alacaksın Ama önce beni
dinleyeceksin bakın coğrafya diğer
bilimlerde olduğu gibi geçmişten
günümüze kadar bir sıralanış var Çağlar
var bu çağlarda farklı farklı gelişimler
sergilemiş bunu kafana oturtm lazım
kodlayın birçok şey dikkat et şimdi
bakın ne var tabii ki her zaman olduğu
gibi eski çağ var Bunları öğreneceğiz
Sonra orta Çağa geçeceğiz sonra Yeni Çağ
yakın Çağa geçeceğiz ilk olarak Eski
çağdan bahsedelim oraya bir not almanı
istiyorum sınavda senden isteyeceği
cümle bu olacak gençler bakın eski çağ
bunlar ilk coğrafyacılar şimdi sana
sınavda sordu eski çağ dedi aklına ne
gelecek hocam bunlar ilk coğrafya
yacılar şimdi ilk coğrafyacıları bir
düşün elimi vurdum ya ilk coğrafyacılar
neden coğrafya yapıyorlar biliyor
musunuz çevreyi anlamak için daha çok bu
coğrafya tasvir çevreyi anlayıp Tasvir
etmek için yapılıyor şu anki anlamda
coğrafya yok ortada sadece çevreye
bakıyorlar bunu anlamaya çalışıyorlar ve
tasvir ediyorlar çevreyi basit bir
coğrafya var yani eğer sana bunun notunu
al oraya tasvir yaz eğer çevreyi böyle
tasvir eden bir yer varsa bir kısım
söylerse sana ha bu en eskisi Hocam çok
ilkel yapıyorlar bu işi diyeceksin
Tasvir etmek çevreye bakıp çevreyi
tasvir ediyorlar Tamam Burası önemliydi
Bak bu çıkacak karşına Kim bunlar birçok
bilim de Gördüğün gibi aristotales Tales
Platon bunlar var Bunlar da var burada
yazabilirsin oraya o eski çağda
gördüklerini buraya yine Aristoteles
talesi yazabilirsin ama bizim için
Şunların üçü çok önemli eski çağda bir
tanesini öğrenmiştik zaten eratos tenes
demiştik ne nasıl kodlamış tık onu
hatırla eratos tenes Eray toost yiyen
Enes Bunlar Okulun
bahçesindeyim esini coğrafya kelimesini
ilk defa Eray la tost yiyen Enes
buluyordu Era tost Enes diyeceksin buna
Anlaştık mı bunu zaten kodlamış tık
tekrar olmuş oldu diğeri Strabon Strabon
diye biri yok Ne var Strabon değil
Amasyalı Strabon diyeceksin Şuraya bak
resme bak Amasya'da gençler gittiğinizde
hemen orada nehrin kenarında alı
strabon'un heykelini görebilirsiniz
orada yaşamış Roma döneminde Amasyalı
Strabon diyeceksin buna Strabon yok
Amasyalı Strabon yine bu da bakın
geografik adlı eser yazmış coğrafya adlı
eser yazmış Roma döneminde gezdiği
yerleri koymuş oraya Strabon yok
Amasyalı Strabon dikkat edin bu isimlere
eski isimler bak eratosten Strabon
Batlamyus Bunların hepsi Tales
Aristoteles Bunlar eski bunları o yüzden
gidip yakın Çağa yeni Çağa koymak diye
karıştırmaz sın bunları hangi çağa
koyacağını da mantıken oturtmanın şimdi
geldim en başa adım adım yavaş yavaş
gideceğim çünkü bu önemli bir konu Şimdi
eski çağ dedi Bana en önemli kısmı ha
hocam burada tasvirler vardı tasvir
ediyorlardı e eski diyorsa eski isimleri
kullanacağım diyeceksin Aristoteles
Tales eratos tenes Eray tos diyen Enes
Amasyalı Strabon Strabon Batlamyus böyle
eski isimleri görünce hemen eski Çağın
içine
yerleştireceğiniz şu Batlamyus şöyle bir
not almanı istiyorum buraya buraya
yabancı ismi yazılmış ama bizim daha çok
karşı za Türkçe ismi çıkacak coğrafya
kılavuzu böyle yazmanı istiyorum
coğrafya bu eser bizim için önemli
karşına çıkabilir coğrafya kılavuzu adlı
eseri yazdı bu şöyle bir dünya haritası
çizmiş Bakın bu batlamyus'un dünya
haritası ve bu gençler sonraki
dönemlerde de çok ciddi kullanılan bir
harita batlamyus'un eserlerinden çok
ciddi yararlanılmış Batlamyus döneminin
önemli coğrafyacıların Baksanıza
koordinat sisteminin olduğu şuraya bakın
koordinat sistemi var koordinat o
dönemde yani koordinat sisteminin olduğu
bir harita çizmiş adam ve bunda da
başarılı olmuş şuraya bakar mısınız
Afrika'yı çizmiş arabistan'ı belirtmiş
burada Türkiye bile var burada bakın
yani Adam Akdeniz kısmını Çok ciddi bir
şekilde gayet başarılı bir şekilde o
döneme göre çok iyi bir şekilde çizmiş
Peki hocam coğrafya kılavuzunu nasıl
kodlayaz Batlamyus coğrafya kılavuzu
benim ismimi biliyor musunuz bilmiyorum
ama belki beni coğrafyanın kodları
olarak biliyorsunuz ama ismim Yunus
coğrafya kılavuzu bakın coğrafya
kılavuzu Yunus Hoca gibi gibi olursa
Batlamyus Yunus var orada bakın
batarsınız Batlamyus dedi birisi bana
tamam mı Batlamyus ha Yunus hoca
batıyordu batırı oldu bizi coğrafya
kılavuzu Yunus Hoca gibi olursa Yunus
hoca olursa batarsınız Batlamyus Aa
Yunus bat batıyordu Yunus hoca coğrafya
kılavuzu Yunus Hoca gibi olursa
batarsınız coğrafya kılavuzu eseri var
bunun unutmuyorsun Tamam batlamyusu da
geçtik şimdi o dönemde önemli olan ne
dedim Daha çok tasvir edilmek tasvirler
var geldik Orta Çağ Şimdi eski çağ dedik
mi o ilk çağ ilk yani ilk ilk taraftaki
en eski insanlar eski insanların
isimlerini koydum Orta Çağ Orta Çağ ile
alakalı ne biliyorsun sen tarih dersinde
de aklında kalmıştır Orta Çağ Karanlık
çağı Karanlık ama batının Karanlık çağı
değil mi Ha bak bu aklına gelir diye
tahmin ediyorum çünkü Orta Çağda
karanlık bir çağ var batıda o zaman kim
yenilik yapacak burada İslam dünyası
Orta Çağ Evet Karanlık Çağ ama batının
karanlığı o zaman bütün her şey İslam
dünyasına geçiyor Eğer ki böyle İslami
isimler duyarsan bakın isimlere Biruni
Muhammed idrisi İbn Batuta mesudi İbn
Haldun hep böyle İslami arapla Araplarla
alakalı isimler var bakın burada görüyor
musunuz böyle İslami isimler
duyduğunuzda ha hocam İslam İslamiyet ne
zaman ön plana çıktı Avrupa ne zaman
geriledi Orta Çağ karanlığında
diyeceksin bakın onu oradan
çağrıştıracak Anladık mı anlatabildim mi
Burada şu var Eşim şimdi İslamiyet ön
planda ya Yani İslam insanlar İslam
coğrafyacıları ön planda O zaman burada
daha çok İslam'la alakalı bir şey olacak
bakın Hac ve Umre Mekke Medine'ye
yapılacak ziyaretlerde kullanılacak
güzergahlar la ilgili çalışmalar
yapılıyor burada coğrafya adına buradaki
mantık Demek ki şöyle bir tekrar edelim
Burası Çünkü çok karışıyor biliyorum O
yüzden ben sana adım adım öğreteceğim
bunu hiç merak etme şimdi eski çağ dedi
biri bana Hoca dedi ki eski çağ ile
alakalı işte 10 puanlık bir soru Yazın
ne biliyorsanız eski çağ hocam burada
daha çok tasvirlerle yapılmış coğrafya
bugün günümüzdeki coğrafya yok burada
daha çok tasvirlerle yapılıyor ha hocam
Aristoteles Tales gibi kişiler var böyle
eski isim başka eratos tanes coğrafyanın
isim babasıydı geografik ismini coğrafya
ismini kullan Amasyalı Strabon vardı
Batlamyus batıyordu yunusa coğrafya
kılavuzu Yunus hoca gibiyse batıyordu
coğrafya kılavuzu eseri vardı bak tak
özet çıkart geldim Orta Çağ dedi biri
bana nasıl çağrışım yapacağını
söylüyorum bak Orta Çağ Karanlık Çağ
geldi ismi aklıma Aa hocam karanlık
çağda Avrupa karanlıkta ama İslamiyet
aydınlıkta O zaman bu dönemde İslamiyet
ön planda diyeceksin İslami isimleri
aklına getireceksin Biruni idrisi İbn
aldun İbn Batuta mesudi böyle İslami
isimleri aklıma getirdim Sonra dedim ki
Hocam burada Mekke Medine hac olayları
var o yüzden o güzergahların
belirlenmesinde coğrafya etkili olmuş
Tamam buraya bir bilgi yazmanı istiyorum
senden Orta Çağda gençler İpek ve
baharat Yolları önemli İpek baharat
yolları tamam mı Bu kelimeyle alakalı
bir etkinlik çıkacak karşına MEB
kitabında İpek baharat denildiğinde Orta
Çağ Gelecek aklına İpek baharatla
beraber önemli göçler oluyor burada
tamam mı önemli göçler İpek baharat ve
önemli göçler yaşanıyor Orta Çağ'da bunu
aklına nasıl getireceksin E şimdi Avrupa
geri kaldı ya İpek ve baharat Yolları
İslamiyet ön planda artık diyeceksin bu
da aklımıza geldi merak etme şurada ben
sana buradaki bütün yazar eserleri
kodlayayım hiç merak etme geldim Yeni
Çağ Şimdi eski çağ en eskiler Orta Çağ
karanlıktı Tamam Yeni Çağ Artık yeni bir
bir dünya açılıyor Ama bunlar
Avrupalılar kendileri için söylemişler
bunu Yeni Bir Dünya Yeni Çağ Yeni Dünya
yeni dünya dediğimiz şey neresi yeni
dünya dediğimiz Şeyi göstereyim size
şimdi bakın gençler Orta Çağ'da Avrupa
karanlıktaydım mı İslamiyet ön plana
çıktı Hac Mekke Medine dedik Sonra
Avrupa Bir de İpek ve baharat yolları da
İslamiyet Osmanlı'nın eline geçiyor İpek
ve baharat da Osmanlıda bütün her şey
parada Osmanlı'da İslamiyette İslam
ülkelerinde Avrupalılar orta çağı
yaşıyor Ama sonra çağdan sonra Yeni Çağ
geliyor yeni dünya keşfediliyor Şimdi
sen ipek ve baharat yollarını aldın mı
Osmanlı olarak paranın kaynağı sana
geçti artık para sende Ticaret Senin
üzerinden dönüyor Avrupalılar bunu
istemiyorlar ve bu iş böyle olmaz deyip
coğrafi keşiflere başlıyorlar bartelmi
dias christof Colomb Vasco de Gama
Macellan gibi insanlar cesaret bulup
Tabii devletlerin desteklemeleri de var
o döneme kadar böyle okyanuslar aşmak
denizlere Gitmek yok Genelde böyle kıyı
kesiminden kıyı kesiminden gidiyor
gemiler ama o o dönem geldiğinde
Osmanlı'nın bu parayı ele geçirmesi İpek
Ticaret yollarını ele geçirmesi artık
Avrupa'nın canına tak ediyor Avrupa'da
Rönesans reformlar yaşanıyor dinin
baskısı da iyice geri plana atılıyor
devletlerin de desteklemesi gemilerin de
sağlam yapılmaya başlanması Bütün bunlar
bir araya geliyor ve o dönem Maceracı
insanlar da ortaya çıkıyor Kaptanlar ve
artık gençler buradan açılmaya
başlıyorlar Biz diyorlar Hindistan'ı
İpek ve baharat yoluyla gitmeyelim
denizden gidelim diyorlar ve gelip Bakın
bu buradan şöyle Afrika'nın güneyinden
Ümit burnuna kadar geliyorlar Ümit
burnunu bartelmi Diaz buluyor sonra
tabii geri geliyor korkuyor Orasının
dünyanın sonu olduğunu düşünüyorlar
Çünkü gerçekten de bakın şöyle Kayalık
değişik bir yer burası dünyanın sonu
düşünüyorlar burayı sonra geri dönüyor
Ümit Burnu Bu yüzden deniyor buraya
sonra tekrar gidiyorlar buradan Vasco de
Gama buradan gidip Hindistan'ı buluyor
Ve artık Osmanlı'nın İpek ve baharat
yollarının önemi giderek kayboluyor İşte
buna Yeni Çağ deniyor Yeni Çağ da bir
şey daha yaşanıyor Maceran dünyayı
dolaşıyor ama onun dışında yeni dünya
dediğimiz Kuzey Amerika ve Güney Amerika
keşfediliyor Bu döneme kadar dünya
buradan ibaret batlamyus'un haritasını
hatırlıyordum değil mi az önce gösterdim
Şurayı gösteriyor dünya buradan ibaretti
ama işte yeni çağda yeni dünyayla
beraber gemilerle beraber Amerika'da
keşfediliyor Amerika'dan çok ciddi
zenginlikler Avrupa'ya akıyor Amerika'da
kabileler var daha gelişmemiş toplumlar
var o dönem hiç kimse yok değil yani Var
ama oradaki altın Zengin Zenginlik ne
varsa Avrupa'ya gidiyor Avrupa
zenginleşiyor yeni çağda Osmanlı
Devleti'nin elindeki paralar
değersizleşen var İpek ve Baharat Yolu
kullanılmasına gerek yok gemilerle
gidiliyor artık işte Bütün bunlar yeni
çağda oluyor nasıl aklına getireceksin
yeni çağda yeni dünya bulunuyordu hocam
yeni dünyanın bulunması var O zaman
böyle bartel midaz Macellan vask Gama
gibi şeyler insanlar var diyeceksin
gelelim notumu bakın bak bartelmi dias
vask Dama
Magellan Christ Kolomb Amerika'yı
buluyordu Sebastian del Cano bu isimler
hep böyle Avrupalı isimler Avrupa ne
zaman öne geçti yeni çağda yeni dünyayla
beraber Demek ki bu isimleri duyarsan
bunlara hemen hocam Coğrafi keşifler
yeni dünya gelecek bak s aklına nasıl
gelmesi gerektiğini göstermeye
çalışıyorum en başa bir daha saralım
şimdi çünkü bu konu Kafanı karıştıran
bir konu biliyorum Merak etmeyin Bakın
ben lise boyunca kafanı ne kadar konu
karıştırıyorsa ben sana onu
anlayabileceğin şekilde anlatmaya çalış
alacağım kodlayayım unutmayacaksın hiç
merak etme şimdi başa dönelim dedi bana
Hoca eski Şah ha eski eski isimler Tales
Aristoteles Batlamyus Strabon eski
isimleri söyledim Tamam coğrafya
kılavuzu Yunus Hoca gibi olursanız
batarsınız batl Yunus Batlamyus Tamam
Orta Çağ Orta Çağ karanlıktı hocam
Karanlık Çağ Avrupa karanlık İslamiyet o
zaman ön planda İpek ve baharat Yolları
Osmanlı'da Bunlar ön planda daha İslami
isimleri sayacağım burada idrisi Biruni
gibi Tamam Yeni Çağ dedi nereden
çağrışım yapacağım Yeni Çağ Yeni Dünya
yeni dünya coğrafi keşiflerle
keşfediliyor Coğrafi keşifler kavrama
aklına gelecek bunu yazacaksın o klasik
soruya Tamam sonra bartelmi Diaz gibi
Vasco de Gema gibi Kristof Kolomb
Macellan gibi Avrupa isimlerini
koyacaksın bunun içerisine coğrafi
keşifleri yapanları Tamam peki hocam
burada Türk isimleri yok mu yani
Osmanlı'da tamamen bitti mi Hemen hemen
bitmedi Tabii hala bir etki var buradaki
Osmanlı'daki kişiler bakın Piri Reis
Seyit Ali Reis Katip Çelebi Evliya
Çelebi dikkat edin Osmanlı'da kullanılan
isimler Bunlar Osmanlı'yı çağrıştırıyor
Katip Çelebi Evliya Çelebi Piri Reis
bunlar böyle daha Osmanlı isimleri
Osmanlı isimlerini duyduğunda böyle
bunları da yeni Çağın içerisine
koyacaksın Tamam bunlarla alakalı Az
sonra ben size göstereceğim mesela Piri
Reis'in eserini öğretirken bunlarla
alakalı bilgi vereceğim ayrıntılı bilgi
vereceğim Merak etmeyin eserlerini de
göstereceğim Az sonra şurada bakın
şurada eserleri var Tamam orada
göstereceğim onları Şimdi burada
bilmemiz gereken bir kişi var ortelius
Şimdi bunu geçmişte anlatmıyorsa
kitabınıza koyuldu geçmiş müfredatta
yoktu o yüzden değerli olduğunu
düşünüyorum ortelius Ne yapmış bu adam
burada değerli olan modern harita olarak
bilinen 70 parça haritayı hazırlamış
Demek ki ilk modern haritayı hazırlayan
adam bu ortelius nasıl kodlayın şimdi
modern haritaya bakın desem nereye
bakarsınız e oradaki tele bakarsınız
değil mi telefona bakarsınız E çünkü
modern harita eski harita olsa eski
haritalara kağıtlara şeylere bakarsınız
ama modern harita diyor Az önce google'
açtığım gibi modern harita diyor modern
haritayı hocam oradaki tele bakarak
öğrenirim bak Modern haritaya bak dedim
şimdi sana ekrandan bana bakıyorsun
modern haritaya baksana diyorum bak
oğlum orada tel var elinde Ya orada bak
orada tel var E oradaki telin içinde
modern harita ortelius ortelius
oradaki telin içinde ne var oradaki
telin içinde modern haritayı yapmış bu
adam güzel bir kod oldu değil mi
geçmişte yoktu bu yeni kodladım bunu
ortelius sizin Böyle daha güzel bir
kodlamanın varsa yorumlara yazın Tamam
mıyız yeni çağdaki de öğrendik geldik
artık Yakın Çağ sildim Yakın Çağ bize
yakın olan Çağ diyeceksin bak Yeni Çağ
ile yakın çağı karıştırıyorsa böyle yap
Yakın Çağ Artık bize yakın olan Çağ
burada bilmen gereken şey ne Bak burada
bilmen gereken şey neydi Eski çağda
tasvir orta çağda Avrupa karanlıktaydım
İslam İslam kısmına geçtik İpek ve
baharat Yolları bilmen gereken bu tek ve
baharat Yolları artık İslamiyet'in
elinde Tamam yeni çağda bilmen gereken
kelime coğrafi keşif kelimesi ha Yeni
Çağ yeni dünya coğrafi keşiflerle
bulundu Tamam Yakın çağda bilmen gereken
kelime ne Burası Bize en yakın olan şey
E o zaman hocam bütün modern coğrafya
burada kuruluyor yani şu modern
coğrafyanın kurucuları modern
coğrafyanın metodolojisi burada
kuruluyor Ne demek bu hani biz şu an
coğrafyayı ayırdık ya ilk dersimizde
dedik ya fiziki coğrafya beşeri coğrafya
b Böyle ayrımlar yaptık değil mi İşte o
ayrımlar ta yakın Çağa kadar yapılmış
ayrımlar değil Yakın çağda yapıldı o
ayrımların Hepsi daha yeni yapıldı yani
işte Yakın çağda gerçek coğrafya bilimi
kuruluyor Anlaştık mı modern coğrafya
Bize en yakın olan çağda kuruluyor demek
modern coğrafyanın kurulduğu yer burada
modern coğrafyada iki tane çok önemli
isim var Bakın bu çıkar işte sınav
sorusudur ha dikkatli dinle Alexander
Von humboldt humboldt şöyle burayı şöyle
yazayım ki Hum BT tam gör diye şöyle
Alexander Von humboldt fiziki
coğrafyanın kurucusu bunun bir eseri var
buraya yaz kozmos aşağıda yazıyor zaten
ama burada anlatacağım ya sana Bunu
şimdi bakın gençler bunu nasıl kodlayan
Von humboldt bak bir şeye benziyor
hüsein Bolt Alexander Von humboldt orada
Alexander Von kısmını geç önemli değil
humboldt Hüseyin Bolt Hüseyin bolt'u
tanıyorsun herhalde dünyaca ünlü koşucu
Hüseyin Bolt fiziğine Baksanıza çok iyi
bir fiziği yok mu ya Ya var ya helal
olsun Aşırı iyi bir fiziği var ve çok
iyi koşmuş çok iyi koşuyor değil mi Ah
ne koşmuş be çok iyi koşmuş bak Hum Bolt
Hüseyin Bolt Fiziği çok iyi ve çok iyi
koşuyor eserinin ismi kozmos koşmuş kim
koşmuş Hüseyin Bolt koşmuş humboldt
koşmuş Fiziği çok iyi değil mi fiziki
coğrafyanın kurucusu Hani fiziki
coğrafya öğretmişti ya size İşte bu
fiziki coğrafyayı bulan adam kuran adam
bu Alexander Von humboldt fiziki Fiziği
çok iyi kimin Hüseyin Bolt'un Fiziği çok
iyi fiziki coğrafyanın kurucusu niye
biliyor musunuz Ben humboldt çuyu
gençler fiziki coğrafyacıyım Ben fiziki
coğrafyayı severim bu adam Güney
Amerika'ya kadar o dönem Bak o dönem
düşünün O dönem Güney Amerika'ya kadar
gitmiş orada Amazon Ormanları dağlar
tepeler her tarafı araştırmış biliyor
musunuz her tarafı gezmiş dolaşmış helal
olsun Ben Mesela humboldt benim benim
Önderim humboldt dur fiziki coğrafyacı
olarak Hüseyin bolt'u öğrendik bir
diğeri de beşeri coğrafyanın kurucusu
Ben bunu pek sevmem masa başı adamı bu
insan coğrafyasının kurucusu Öyle dağ
tepe falan dolaşmasına gerek yok masa
başında insanla ilişkisini yorumluyor
beşeri coğrafyanın kurucusu kim Carl
ritter bitter Bihter Bihter Bihter
Bihter de diyebiliriz Bihter Karl Bihter
Bir de arabaya biniyor Karl kar arabaya
biniyor bak hep insan var işin içinde
görüyor musunuz İnsan bir de bitter
çikolatayı yiyor orada masa başına
oturmuş Tabii orada beşeri coğrafya
insan coğrafyasını kuruyor arabasına
oturmuş bitter çikolata yiyor Oh keyfi
yerinde arabasında Bihter Bihter bitter
Ç beşeri insanı çağrıştırıyor bak hep
insan Bihter kim insan insan
coğrafyacısı kurucusu da bitter Karl
ritter Richter tamam mı kozmos koşmuş
hocam kim humboldt fiziki coğrafyanın
kurucusu geldik buraya blanch blan diye
okuyalım bunu blan blanch blan Pan blan
blan blan banı varmış bunun Bak Blanc
çıktığında karşımıza ya Bu Nasıl planlı
bir adam ya planlı biri Bak bu planlı
kim böyle planlı olur politikacılar
değil mi politikacılar böyle çok planlı
planlı planlı insanlar BL planlı
insanlar bunlar planlı He diyeceksin bak
pl plan He planlı insan bu
politikacılar planlı insan bu
politikacılar diyeceksin politik
jeopolitik okulunun kurucusu Bu da bir
de şuna bakın ratzel Ah bunlar ratzel
bunlar elleri ayakları bak rahat Bunlar
çok rahat ratzel rahat zel rahat zel
rahatlar Bunlar siyasetçiler Çünkü bu
siyasetçiler ne rahatlar değil mi Oh
Eller ensede rahat el Oh bak ratzel
rahat el rat zel Bunlar ah bu
siyasetçiler ne rahatlar Bunlar Ah ah
tamam mı Bir tane daha var var şunu bir
de tekrar edelim ortel ortelius orada
tel var Aa modern harita telefonda Tamam
Carl ortwin Sauer artık nasıl okunuyorsa
bilmiyorum siz nasıl okunuyorsa yazın
aşağıya sauna Sauer saunalı yer saunalı
yer sau yeri duyduğun zaman saunalı yer
diyeceksin Ah be bizim kültürümüzde hiç
sauna Yok be bak Ben Trabzonluyum saun
mış hamamm Benim kültürüm de hiç yok
Tokat'a gittik Geçen geziye Bu arada ben
Türkiye'ye geziyorum biliyor musunuz
biliyorsunuzdur herhalde değil mi Şöyle
Gençler ben bu kanalı 4 yıl önce kurdum
3,5 yıl önce o dönem kanalı ilk
kurduğumda gezerek böyle coğrafya
anlatacağım göreceğim göstereceğim Bütün
Türkiye'yi bütün şehirleri tek tek
gezeceğim diye bir hedefle çıkmıştım
yola 1 milyon olacağım ve gezmelere
çıkacağım demiştim Geçenlerde 1 milyon
olduk karavanımızı da aldık karavanla
beraber geziyorum 15 gün bir şehre
gidiyorum 15 gün o şehirde kalıp 15 gün
boyunca bütün ilçelerini gezip sonra
geri geliyorum 15 günde evde videolar
çekiyorum bu ders videolarını çekiyorum
sonra tekrar gün başka bir şehre
gidiyorum o gideceğim şehri de anketle
belirliyorum mesela şu ana kadar
nereleri gezdiğimi göstereyim size
arkada harita vardı bilmiyorum gördünüz
mü bir dakika hemen video kamerayı alıp
geliyorum nereleri gezdiğimi göstereyim
telefonu aldım Gelin şimdi bakın Bu
benim haritam şimdi bu gez kazı şeklinde
bir harita bakın ilk Tokat'a gittik
Sonra anket açtık yine Tokat'ın yanına
gittik sonra 3 anket açtım az daha yine
Sivas çıkıyordu tokatın yanındaydı
Allah'tan Sivas çıkmadı Şimdi önümü eki
gezi Diyarbakır olacak Diyarbakır'ı
kazıyacağız Tabii bunun için ilk önce şu
9 sınıf videolardan ilerletmeli derse
dur kaynatmayın dersi Evet ben şu an
geziyorum Hatta bu videoyu attıktan
sonra 1 Ekim gibi diğer bakır'da
gideceğim Sen belki bu videoyu 3 sene
sonra falan izliyorsun belki Türkiye
haritasının çoğunu kazmış bile olur
tahminim 67 yıl boyunca böyle gezeceğim
ben bu hikayeyi niye anlatıyorum ya ha
Benim kültürüm mesela sauna yok E şimdi
biz karavanla dolaşıyoruz duş almamız
lazım Tokat'ta Hamama gittik çok güzeldi
Tokatlılar kültüründe hamam var sauna
var niye Hocam bunu anlatıyorsun sau er
diyor sauna olan yer diyor sauna Benim
kültürüm de yok ama Tokatlılar
kültüründe var kültürel coğrafyanın
gelişmesine önemli katkılar sunmuştur
diyeceksin kültürel coğrafya burada
önemli olan Tamam saer sauna kültürel
kültür diğeri buraya kadar Tamam mıyız
Tamam Türkiye'de gençler Bir de bizim
ülkemizde de ble Cumhuriyetin ilk
yıllarında önemli coğrafyacılar vardı
isim darkot Faik Sabri Duran Mesela biz
Reşat ıbın izbak iz Bak'ın kitaplarıyla
çok çalıştık üniversitedeyken Oğuz
Eroğlu Sırrı Erinç özellikle bunların
kitaplarını çok gördük bunlardan çok
çalıştık bunlar Türkiye'de coğrafyanın
kurucuları Evet şimdi gelelim size
sınavda sorulacak yazar eser kısımlarına
Strabon Amasyalı Strabon onun 17 ciltlik
coğrafya eseri var o çok çıkmaz
karşınıza ama Batlamyus coğrafya
kılavuzu coğrafya kılavuzu Yunus Hoca
gibi olan sardı Batlamyus bunu kodlamış
Biruni kodlayalım Biruni maksadım bir
kanun yazmak diyeceksin Biruni Biruni
dediğinde birisi sana Biruni maksadım
bir kanun yazmak kanun El maksudi Biruni
maksadım bir kanun yazmak hocam Biruni
maksadım bir kanun yazmak Yani kanun el
maksudi çıktığında karşına e kanun
Yazmak bir kanun yazmak şöyle yapacaksın
bir kanun yazmak maksadım ha hocam bu
Biruni diyeceksin Tamam bunun kodlaması
böyle idrisi kitap ür rüşandi
üşendiği çıktı a üşendiğin kim
üşeniyan İdris babaya nasıl yürüyordu
Öyle Ağır ağır üşene üşene Gençler bu
böyle şöyle önemli Şimdi bunlar
çıktığında eşleştirme olarak çıkabilir
karşınıza ya da test sorusu olarak çık
ğında da karşınıza ya da bu eseri verir
kimindir der idrisi yazarsın kitap ür
rüşandi der neydi la bu kimindi Der
diğinde
üşendiği Oldu diyeceksin İbn Haldun
bunun kodlamasını size bırakıyorum İbn
Haldun dediğinde nasıl aklımıza
mukaddime gelebilir bunun kodlaması Siz
de yorumlara yazın sabitleyin üstü
mukaddime İbn Haldun ben tam var Bir
tane eski konu anlatımlarında yapıyordum
ama tam oturmuyor kafamda size
bırakıyorum bunu geldim buraya Piri Reis
çok çıkar bakın Asıl bu çıkacak
karşınıza piriz bak kitabı bahriyye
baharı kitabı Bahriye Bahar Ah pireli
baharı Piri Reis reise at kitabı Bahriye
A bu pireli Bahar diyeceksin Bahar bak
kitabı Bahriye pireli Bahar bu hocam
Piri Reis pireli Bahardı Hocam bu
diyeceksin kitabı Bahriye pireli Bahar
pire Piri Reis getirecek Katip Çelebi
bak Katip Çelebi kitap bir tane kitap
var kitabın içinden çihan çıkıyor çihan
biliyor musunuz Bir öyle bir hayvan
kitabın içinden çihan çıkıyor Katip
Çelebi dedi bana biri a hocam Katip
kitap kitaptan Cihan çıkıyordu di Cihan
nüma o şekilde çağrışım yapacak Kaşkarlı
Mahmut Divanı lügatı Türk Bunu zaten
Türkçe dersinde edebiyat dersinde
biliyorsunuzdur ama illa kodlayan ben
şöyle kodluyorum bunu divanın lügatı
Türk Divan Divanı biliyorsunuzdur
yatılan yer kaşarları kurutmak için
divana yat kırmışlar kaşarları Divan
üstünde kurutuyorlar mış benim aklıma
buradan geliyor Evliya Çelebi
Seyahatnamesi bunu böyle ben öğreniyorum
yani Evliya Çelebi demiyorum Evliya
Çelebi Seyahatnamesi hep böyle bil Bunu
Evliya Çelebi diye biri yok Evliya
Çelebi Seyahatnamesi var Evliya Çelebi
Seyahatnamesi Ben bu adamı seviyorum
Aslında ben bundan esinlendim Türkiye'ye
dolaşırken adam o dönemlerde Bütün her
tarafı dolaşmış düşünün birçok yeri
dolaşmış Biz şu an bu kadar imkan var
elimizde bir coğrafyacı olarak
dolaşmıyor ben bundan esinlendim Ben de
şu an bir Seyahatname yazıyorum Türkiye
Seyahatnamesi yazıyorum tek tek Tokat
bitti Ordu bitti Diyarbakır Bir gün
gelecek Diyarbakır da bitmiş olacak tek
tek hepsini kazıyıp hepsini tek tek
bitireceğim Evliya Çelebi'nin
Seyahatnamesi gibi ben de kendi
Seyahatnamesi olacak kanaldan videoları
izleyebilirsiniz gençler Alexander Von
Hum Bolt Hüseyin Bolt güzel koşuyordu
dedi değil mi Bunu da öğrendik Evet ne
yaptık coğrafya biliminin gelişimini
bitirdik Evet gençler Coğrafya biliminin
gelişim imi de bitti oradaki o yazarlar
eserler Sana anlattıklarım o kadar
değerliydi ki Oturup bunu ezberlemekle
uğraşma o yazarları eserleri
ezberlemekle uğraşma kodlama hafıza
tekniklerini sana gösterdiğim gibi yap
çok işine yarayacak Evet bu ders Bitmedi
bu dersten sonra bütün ünitenin ünite
genel tekrarı 1ci ünitenin ünite genel
tekrarı var o dersi O soruları
çözdüğünde orada etkinlikler var
etkinlikleri yaptığımızda asıl Bu ders
bitmiş olacak Hala kafanda oturmamıştır
ne kadar kodlama yapsak da oturmasını
mümkün değil Çünkü pekiştirmeden konuyu
öğrendik Bir saat sonra hemen diğer
video geliyor ünite genel tekrar videosu
ünite genel tekrar videosuyla bütün
üniteyi bitirdiğinde asıl öğrenmiş
olacaksın evet ünite genel tekrarı
videosunda görüşmek dileğiyle O zaman ne
diyoruz Yunus hocayla bir defa öğren bir
daha asla unutma Bu derse de Paraf attık
ünite genel tekrar videosunda görüşmek
üzere